avez-vous un fils qui de son vivant
répondait au nom des Mathilde
il n'avait jamais eu d'ennuis à Chicago
pas plus qu'un autre jeune homme
[Musique]
avez-vous expliqué à votre fils de
quelle façon il devrait se conduire mais
si si tu m'écoutes
ils ont des règles différentes là-bas
fais-toi tout petit le temps que tu
seras
[Musique]
aimez tous les seulement partir en
vacances et s'amuser avec ses cousins
je voulais préserver son innocence j'ai
tout fait pour que son enfance ne lui
soit pas volé
il ne s'est jamais dit que quelque chose
pourrait lui arriver
c'est bien ce garçon là
le corps des maîtres vient d'être
retrouvé mort
je dois vous préparer
tu pourrais m'apporter le costume des
mecs le noir c'est comme ça qu'il
voudrait être fait beau n'est pas en
état d'être vu par qui que ce soit tout
à fait en étage justement cette odeur
monsieur c'est celle du corps de mon
fils en pestant la haine raciale
suivez-moi je vous prie
le monde entier toi foire ce qu'on a
fait à mon fils
les photos elles ont transformé la vie
des gens
nous avons une opportunité
en quoi risquer ta vie lui rendre
service
je dois me montrer forte pour mon enfant
et mon enfant à moi alors
témoigné contre un homme blanc et
survécu
il y a à peine un mois j'avais un joli
appartement à Chicago j'avais un fils
quand un malheur arrivait à des Noirs
dans le sud je me disais et bien c'est
leur problème pas le mien mais
aujourd'hui je sais que ce qui arrive à
n'importe lequel d'entre nous ou que ce
soit dans le monde doit impérativement
être notre problème à tous
[Musique]